[Musique]
bonsoir vous retrouver pour ce nouveau
c'est 8 écossais tu étais qu dédié cette
fois ci à la mobilité
voici les titres nous irons rencontrer
thierry mettait le responsable france de
l'entreprise et des f1 l'équipementier
automobile allemand basé à
voisins-le-bretonneux qui est leader en
sécurité nous ferons aussi un point sur
l'entreprise des vestaires une
entreprise située à voisins le
bretonneux qui forment des
professionnels de la route grâce à des
simulateurs de conduite
et puis nous avons interviewé olivier
meyer le président de steven design à
maurepas une société spécialisée dans le
design automobile et l'aéronautique
mais faisons un point sur le parc
automobile en dehors les yvelines et à
saint quentin en yvelines les yves hinse
est le premier département automobile de
france le territoire regroupe au total
150 entreprises automobiles le secteur
emploie plus de 45 mille salariés de
grandes entreprises automobiles font
partie de notre région comme chrysler
rattrape nissan west europe à voisins le
bretonneux ou encore le technocentre
renault à guyancourt
on ne peut parler de mobilité plus
précisément d'automobiles sont faire un
point sur la société sdf un
équipementier automobile allemand qui
est installé à voisins le bretonneux et
qui génère aujourd'hui un chiffre
d'affaires de 35 milliards d'euros
zdf est un acteur important en termes de
mobilité nique à l'ennemi doro a
interviewé le responsable france de la
viande
alors oui haussmann je suis dans les
locaux 2 nf à voisins-le-bretonneux un
équipementier automobile allemand l'un
des plus grands fournisseurs de
technologies de transmission deux
châssis et de sécurité alors pour vous
parler de cette société je suis avec tyr
et mettez le responsable france de la
marque
alors thierry est ce que vous nous
présentez un petit peu votre marque qui
n'est pas connue forcément du grand
public
oui elle n'est pas forcément connu parce
qu'on veut vivre en direct les
constructeurs automobiles mais j'ai
quand même connu de tous les
spécialistes puisque
les meilleures boîtes de vitesses
automatiques sont zdf et qu'une partie
de la sécurité et viennent aussi du
groupe gdf alors c'est est un groupe
allemand vous l'avez dit c'est 35
milliards de chiffre d'affaires 35
milliards d'euros
ses 157 a devancé un gros poids lourds
donné un indice quotidien des trois plus
grands équipementiers au monde et donc
on écoule avilit spécialisé dans les
transmissions et boîtes de vitesses dans
les châssis composants de châssis on
sait gérer la lauter du châssis avec la
suspension latéral avec la direction et
le longitudinale avec le freinage et on
fait tous les moyens de retenue airbags
ceintures volant et puis maintenant
toutes les caméras les radars qui
permettent la conduite autonome en tout
cas dès aujourd'hui l'assistance à la
conduite
vous fabriquez combien de châssis tous
les jours
le châssis tous les jours difficile à
dire précisément mais imaginez que edf a
à peu près selon les produits entre 15 %
et 30 % du marché mondial
donc on fabrique 100 millions de
véhicules au monde
donc imaginez ce que ça peut représenter
boîte de vitesses automatiques ont fait
3 millions de boîtes par an vous est
essentiellement centré sur la mobilité
la mobilité qu'est ce que c'est
finalement chez edf la mobilité c'est
pour nous c'est le domaine premier c'est
d'améliorer l'efficacité de la chaîne de
traction c'est à dire réduire le co2
donc donc pour nous la mobilité c'est
apporter une performance aux véhicules
tout en important l'environnement qui
est le co2
donc on va s'évertuer à travailler à
développer à proposer aux constructeurs
des produits qui vont améliorer
aujourd'hui le co2 donc ils vont
améliorer l'environnement et quels sont
justement les grands projets pour les
années à venir pour 2017
au total les grands projets aujourd'hui
c'est de
généraliser tous les éléments qui vont
améliorer la sécurité et la mobilité
donc c'est de développer des boîtes de
vitesse pour les véhicules de demain
c'est de développer les équipements pour
les véhicules hybrides ou électriques et
pour demain c'est de développer les
fonctions de sécurité passive
c'est-à-dire toutes les radars caméras
qui ont aidé à réduire les accidents
l'accidentologie
alors ici on est à saint quentin en
yvelines oui juste à côté il ya le
technocentre renault de guyancourt il ya
notamment également mercedes qui est à
montier bretonneux deux grosses marques
c'était un choix de s'implanter ici à
voisins bretons ne au plus proche il ya
vingt concurrents fin ou des partenaires
il n'ya pas que ces deux marques il ya
aussi le centre de développement de psa
à vélizy dans les yvelines et un grand
les yvelines est un grand département de
l'automobile donc il ya plein de
start-up également qui se lancent dans
la mobilité
oui c'est important pour nous d'être sur
l'ouest parisien d'être aussi sur paris
parce que c'est une plaque tournante
d'un hub européen en tout cas on est un
groupe mondial donc on se déplace aussi
souvent travers le monde d'être à paris
dans l'ouest parisien c'était quand même
important et une émulation peut-être
entre tous ces sites une émulation non
il ya des partenariats
il ya de bonnes relations entre tous et
si vous comptez rester encore longtemps
ici à saint quentin en yvelines continue
à développer la marque comme moody's et
la sécurité et mobilité
nous suivons nos constructeurs donc nos
constructeurs sont globaux nous sommes
globaux c'est-à-dire que nous sommes non
seulement en france mais par tout le
monde
la marque va encore grossir pour les
années à venir le groupe fait 35
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
je pense que 2020 2025 on peut
s'attendre à des chiffres nettement
supérieurs
on en interne on estime qu' on devrait
atteindre 45 milliards
à 5 ans et pourquoi avoir choisi
voisins-le-bretonneux justement parler
de tous ces lieux où autour de du
technocentre renault 2 voilà ce qu'est
ce qui lie à une principale raison est
ce que c'était la seule raison ou est ce
qu'il y avait une autre raison
où sont la principale raison tient
principale raison est au niveau du cou
de la marque
on parlait tout à l'heure des voitures
autonome est-ce que c'est l'avenir
finalement de nouvelles voitures de
demain
oui ça dépend qu'est ce que vous mettez
dans le mot demain si c'est demain en
2020 non c'est pas l'avenir et c'est
2030 oui c'est l'avenir
la clavicule autonome demande énormément
énormément de validation on parle
aujourd'hui de d'un milliard de
kilomètres pour pouvoir garantir
véhicules autonomes tout le parc ne sera
pas autonome en même temps donc ça sera
des véhicules qu'on verra sur les routes
par petites doses dès 2022 23 mai on
pourra pas parler de généralisation
avant 2030 ou 35,7 trek très compliqué
merci beaucoup thierry may t il bientôt
merci a bientot merci d'immobilité dit
aussi amélioration de la conduite
nous avons décidé de faire un focus sur
l'entreprise des vestaires une société
située à voisins le bretonneux qui a
pour but de former des professionnels de
la route grâce à des simulateurs de
conduite des vestaires est une société
viennoise qui est l'une des pionnières
en ce qui concerne les simulateurs de
conduite le but apprendre à des
professionnels ou non à réduire leur
temps de réaction face à une situation
de risque mais je vais rouler beaucoup
plus près du véhicule qui est devant et
vous verrez à ce moment-là mieux la
distance de sécurité qui est laissée pas
à le conducteur
le sénateur s'est déjà de permettre aux
conducteurs de vivre à peu près toutes
les situations qu'il pourra un jour ou
l'autre
rencontrés sur la route puisque le
sénateur c'est un outil qui est très
souple il permet de conduire en ville
sur route sur autoroute de jour de nuit
sous la pluie par temps de brouillard et
il va permettre également de réaliser
des exercices techniques apprendre à
freiner d'urgence et s'est passé présidé
aujourd'hui toutes les voitures sont
équipées de la déesse antiblocage de
roues
c'est relativement simple de freiner à
100% d'efficacité mais ça ne s'improvise
pas et la société propose tout type de
formation pour les voitures les vélos ou
encore les bus et le simulateur séduit
les professionnels de la conduite
les gens sont satisfaits puisque bas il
renouvelle d'année en année les
formations et puis bah comme monsieur
d'inventaire si vous voulez remet à
chaque fois des nouveaux scénarios sa
basse et c'est toujours enrichissant de
travailler avec nous parce que là on
n'arrête pas de progresser par pour la
sous le temps et donc si on progresse
les entreprises province etc
et c'est pour ça qu'on a fidélisé pas
mal de l'entreprise quoi avec deux
millions de chiffre d'affaires des
belles terres vise aujourd'hui
l'international
elle a déjà exporté plusieurs de ses
simulateurs à l'étranger faisons
l'emploi un pont sur la société still in
design l'entreprise oeuvre dans le
domaine du design auprès de grands
constructeurs automobiles et
aéronautiques et nautiques nous avons
rencontré olivier meyer le président de
cnn design donc bonjour monsieur meyer
bonjour présenté moi un petit peu still
in design messieurs avec plaisir donc
c'était line designs est une société qui
aura bientôt huit ans et qui est
spécialisée dans le design industriel
pour le transport en gros tout ce qui
roule skiff le tout ce qui vole alors
c'est quoi votre particularité alors
utilisé à une des grosses activités
design et surtout tous les moyens de
matérialisation et de fabrication avec
6500 mètres carrés d'ateliers ici au se
trouve au pôle design 35 designer et
modeleur numérique et ici on crée
les nouveaux produits pour nos clients
grosse activité automobile mais
également aéronautique et nautiques
c'est rare d'avoir cette partie
production dans une société non oui bien
sûr vous avez des agences de design qui
sont très spécialisés sur design ou des
prototypes et ce qu'ils font des
maquettes
nous on couvre toute la chaîne de
création d'un nouveau produit
partant d'une esquisse d'une idée
jusqu'à un objet échelle 1 qui permettra
à nos clients de matérialiser et de
décider la suite à donner au projet soit
ce sera un succès ou éventuellement des
choses à reprendre
c'est un plus pour le client de voir
tout ça en fait assez c'est
indispensable
c'est indispensable la partie maquette
permet de détecter tous les derniers
défauts qu'on ne voit pas sur la mecque
partie numérique et donc quand on fait
une maquette on arrête le développement
numérique et on reprend à partir de tous
les défauts qu'on aura identifié à
partir des maquettes physique
vous avez la partie automobile vous en
rêviez c'était l'année 2016 comment ça
s'est passé pour vous as une année de
forte croissance dans le secteur
aéronautique de matières de nos
positions dans le secteur automobile qui
reste le premier secteur de l'entreprise
mais l'aéronautique pèse à plus de 30%
maintenant sur notre chiffre d'affaires
et avec des grands clients comme zodiac
air france airbus hélicoptère airbus ou
dassault aviation vous êtes dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est ça pullule d'entreprises liées à
l'automobile à l'aéronautique
c'est sa porte véritablement un plus oui
on est dans des activités qui
nécessitent une proximité avec nos
clients
alors autant dans les directions projet
avec les designers et la qualité des
projets elle se fait dans cette
communication permanente surtout sur la
fin des projets et donc il ya besoin
d'avoir cette proximité donc
effectivement on est proche de psa à
vélizy et de renault à guyancourt et
mais également d'autres clients dassault
aviation typiquement quai à saint-cloud
lé parlement un petit peu de l'année
2017 qui est déjà là oui c'est quoi les
prochains plans les prochaines idée
écoutez on a des développements fort
dans l'automobile toujours mais
également dans le secteur aéronautique
avec un contact avec un certain nombre
de compagnies aériennes majeures et des
développements de nouveaux sièges
business et éco mais là je peux pas vous
en dire plus ah d'accord ok sur le côté
international alors oui pleinement
pleinement dans le côté international
avec ces compagnies aériennes ray mais
vous pouvez pas vous en dire plus et non
mais vous viendrez mais l'avenir
s'annonce côté au travail à c'est pas
facile tous les jours ni pour nos
clients et même donc on accompagne leurs
propres problématiques et voilà on vous
retrouvera sur des salons j'imagine ou
pas du tout les mois à venir alors nous
directement non par contre on existe sur
les salons pour les les produits que
l'on fait pour nos clients typiquement
au prochain salon de genève en mars sur
un véhicule qui est en cours de
fabrication là dans les ateliers sur
lesquels on a eu une belle activité de
création c'est pareil je peux pas vous
en parler pour l'instant puisque ça bon
ça reste confidentielle mon agent
discute en off on va voir merci merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
une date à noter le séminaire sur la
cyber sécurité organisée par optis
valais aura lieu le 31 janvier au crédit
agricole à guyancourt
le but de l'événement est de mettre en
relation les entreprises avec les
professionnels de la cybersécurité situe
t co c'est fini on se retrouve dans 15
jours
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]